you did something that sounds like it
raised a lot of money but also sounds
like something spectacular I really wish
I had seen this which is you did a
feeding America and you did it with a
table read yeah of a script with the
entire cast of big mouth I would love to
see you guys do that it was a live table
read over zoom with with basically our
entire cast and yeah and and we we did
it we did it on zoom and and it went
straight into YouTube and throughout we
just tried to amplify feeding America
which is a great organization that is
trying to help
everyone in need who needs food and they
support over 200 food banks around the
country and there so we were able
through that a live broadcast on YouTube
and then it's still up on YouTube if
people want to see it check it out yeah
it's it's it's a great idea and you guys
have such an amazing cast that and it's
also one of those shows where it's fun I
would imagine because I am a fan of big
mouths and I know a lot of you guys
personally but to see you do the
characters and then be able to imagine
the characters as they're animated would
be really fun yeah it was great it was
and I think honestly it was pretty early
in into this whole thing and it was I
think nice for everybody to get together
just even over zoom and see each other
and do something that felt a little
lighter and and also for hopefully
people out in in in the world like just
to give them something to watch yeah I
think we're extraordinarily lucky to be
working in a weird business where we can
still do what we do from home I feel
very grateful about that I mean that
yeah that you and I it can still make
this ridiculous foolishness and and be
you know keeping people employed and
working with our people over Xoom men
we're extraordinarily lucky we're very
lucky to get to do that we are not most
a lot of people are not having that
experience and so I'm I'm very I feel
very grateful and I'm you know just
trying to figure out ways that we can
help other people who are not in in this
privileged situation for any number of
reasons